we're going to switch gears for you the
U.S is seeing a rise in the popularity
of weight loss drugs like ozempic and
wagovi the increase is being driven by
celebrities in those viral social media
videos showing dramatic weight loss
Transformations but the high demand is
also squeezing supplies for the diabetic
patients ozempic is FDA approved for
type 2 diabetes patients but can be
prescribed for weight loss and will Gobi
is approved by the FDA for people with
obesity we're also at risk of heart
disease at or at large for public health
at Kaiser health news is Dr Celine
gounder she joins us at the table she is
by the way our CBS News medical
contributor it's always good to see you
in your signature scarves I have to say
so we're going to talk about the weight
loss drugs in just a second but let's
start with picking up on the story from
Chris the earthquake in in turkey as a
public health official what are your
biggest concerns when you look at that
health-wise after the initial injuries
that you would sustain people would
sustain in an earthquake you're really
looking at a few other things that we
would worry about so one is dialysis
because people don't have electricity to
run the dialysis machines and you can't
really go very long without dialysis if
you are somebody who has kidney disease
and needs dialysis sepsis is another one
so with these injuries people might have
had maybe they survived the earthquake
but you know they have skin abrasions
other things could even be unrelated to
the earthquake that they have an
infection and because they're not able
to get Rapid Care that can go on to
sepsis yeah I mean we're watching
because they're cruises you see are
working 24 7 but it's heartbreaking it's
the imagery that we see in the sounds
that we hear that get to me but the the
whole bigger story there with the health
issues let's talk about the weight loss
drugs because people who have struggled
with the health with a weight issue and
I'm a member of that club the struggle
is real always keep thinking I wish
there was a pill that I could take and
now there are peers there is a pill that
you could take but you have a butt to
that so
um ozampic and wagovi are both
injections you would take once a week
they do work very well as long as you're
on them and that's the hitch so how do
these work they stimulate the pancreas
to make more insulin they make you feel
Fuller faster they reduce your appetite
but again if you're not on them
basically for the rest of your life the
weight comes right back on Is it
feasible to be on them for the rest of
your life these drugs are really
expensive so you're talking about
fifteen thousand dollars a year so if
you're a celebrity who makes millions of
dollars a year yeah maybe you can afford
it but for the average person
um it's it's really unaffordable
Medicaid Medicare don't cover these
drugs and then even private insurance
regular Insurance May not cover these
especially if you don't meet the very
strict criteria in terms of diabetes and
some of these other heart risky
conditions Dr gallender I wonder this I
have a couple of friends who take it
they don't they're not a diabetic right
they're doing it just for the aesthetic
reasons and here's what I wonder will
they be more dependent on it if you stay
on it for beauty reasons in 10 years are
we going to find out well maybe you're
more prone to diabetes because you did
that we don't know you know people talk
about worrying about the long-term risks
of vaccines we really don't know the
long-term risks of drugs like ozempic
and wagovi so in five years will they be
dependent on them well at least for the
weight loss part of it absolutely we see
people regain the weight within a year
and sometimes much faster than that
there are other long-term risks of being
on these drugs so we see an increased
risk of pancreatitis so it's
inflammation of the pancreas gallstones
kidney disease and in rodents we have
seen an increased risk of thyroid cancer
so it can mess with your pancreas if if
you're not a diabetic is that what
you're saying well the way it works is
to stimulate your pancreas so anything
that can stimulate your pancreas could
also cause inflammation of the pancreas
so that is a risk with these drugs what
about in the short term I mean obviously
one of the side effects the one that
people are going for is you lose weight
but do you feel any kind of discomfort
in the meantime yeah yeah vomiting
diarrhea some people really can't
tolerate these drugs because the nausea
is so bad so it you know it depends some
people can tolerate them some people
can't should this be something that
insurance covers or is this sort of like
you know it's an aesthetic thing as
David said it's not really Health well
for some people it is a health thing so
you know for diabetics who have high
blood pressure high cholesterol and
other medications don't work but 40
percent of Americans are obese and if
you had to treat at fifteen thousand
dollars a year 40 40 of Americans you're
looking at trillions of dollars more
than we already spent on health care so
it's not feasible to do that so I really
think insurance companies are going to
be pretty strict in terms of who they're
going to cover this medication for so if
you're sitting here and you're watching
the results the social media videos are
amazing if you're looking at the results
and you say I'm willing to take that
chance do you think it's worth taking
that chance
unless you can afford to spend fifteen
thousand dollars a year out of pocket
for the rest of your life look the
weight's gonna come raging back on but
it comes right back on Celine regardless
of what you do you're talking to someone
who's been on the hot dog diet the
Cabbage
Weight Watchers all of it yeah but it
does come back on if you don't do the
right thing no but if you don't you
think you have to stick with the habits
you know that really help you with the
weight loss which is especially what you
eat oh I know absolutely that's we all
know what we have to do we just don't we
don't want to do it's very hard it's
very difficult but I mean if you really
want to sweat though fifteen thousand
dollars a year yeah that's a lot heavy
bird uh Dr Celine Gander thank you very
much for walking us through